happy couturier to everybody as we
discuss the brief a brief history of
poliomyelitis it's really a pleasure and
a privilege to have our colleague
professor Vincent Bracken yellow here
he's made many distinguished
contributions to the understanding of
viruses including making the first DNA
copy of an RNA virus and demonstrating
in this case polio demonstrating that
that it's infectious which led to many
new avenues in virology and and the
capability of changing viruses and
studying viruses in many new ways
professor rack and yellow is the Higgins
professor of microbiology and immunology
at Columbia at the College of Physicians
and Surgeons and also teachers of I
Rolla G course here on the Morningside
campus so we're delighted to welcome him
back to discuss a brief history of
poliomyelitis thank you Thank You
Stephen I always felt that bit lucky too
because this is a virus with a very rich
history
there's no mobile Mike oh yeah lucky
with polio to have a great history i'm
going to try and give you a sense of
that today but let's start first by can
anyone tell me who i stole this title
from anyone know Stephen Hawking Stephen
Hawking who said that you very good I
don't have a prize for you but it's
right so about 15 years ago I read a
brief history of time and I was
impressed that a scientist a very good
scientist could convey what they're
doing to the public and that at that
time inspired me to do some of the
things that I'm doing today reaching out
to the public and trying to teach them
about viruses and I'll tell you a bit
about that later what I would like to do
today is to give you an overview of the
history of this virus as a paralytic
agent but we're going to mix in some
biology because I am a research
scientist I've worked in the lab on
polio my whole career and I want to give
you some of that because I think it's
important to understand the history of
this disease to understand the agent as
well but first we'll defined
poliomyelitis the disease caused by this
virus the word comes from the
combination of two Greek roots polio for
grey mile on for matter poliomyelitis
and itís of course the Latin meaning
inflammation and here is a description
of the disease from a 1959 textbook of
Medicine this is no longer in textbooks
of Medicine of course a common acute
viral disease characterized clinically
by a brief febrile illness with sore
throat headache and vomiting often with
stiffness of the neck and back in many
cases a lower neuron paralysis develops
in the early days of illness so we will
actually deconstruct that statement
completely and we'll try to explain how
the virus does this
as far as we can tell this disease has
been around for a long time we don't
have any clinical isolates from the 18th
Egyptian dynasty but we have this
carving or steel which shows this priest
with a drop foot which is very typical
of polio it maybe it's not polio but a
number of individuals have suspected
that it might be in this dates from 1582
1350 BC throughout history from this
point on there are sporadic descriptions
of various diseases which may or may not
have been polio so we don't have a
coherent record but I suspect that the
virus has been around for thousands of
years in humans at least the first very
good clinical account of this disease
was made by this London pediatrician
Michael Underwood in 1789 in a book
called treatise on diseases of children
his is he is clearly describing
poliomyelitis in this book and from the
Egyptian steel up until this point as we
said we have sporadic descriptions of
what could be this disease so I suspect
it was around for a long time but it was
quite rare and did not occur in
epidemics as we will see later epidemic
poliomyelitis began at the end of the
1800s and by epidemics of course we mean
larger numbers of cases not individual
cases here and there the first one in
Sweden in eighteen sixty eight fourteen
cases and then also in 1881 the first in
the US was in Vermont in 1894 132 cases
and I was studied by the local coroner
and he made some very astute
observations about the disease which can
find in the literature which is which
have helped us understand the nature of
it to this day an important observation
was made by Swedish physician in 1887
who noted an initial systemic phase of
the disease that is generalized symptoms
fever malaise aches and pains and
involvement of the central nervous
system
that is the paralysis seemed to be a
complication it was very astute he
noticed it didn't happen in everyone and
so he said maybe it's just a
complication and we will get back to
this of course a bit later we now call
polio a disease of modern sanitation so
I've just told you around the turn of
the 20th century began to emerge an
epidemic form and we believe this is
because of the improved sanitation that
was developed around that time so before
that year polio circulated freely in the
population it's spread by the fecal-oral
route as we will see and it infected
most children shortly after birth and so
they became immunized when we improved
sanitation that delayed infection until
later in life and one theory is that the
children at birth are given antibodies
from their mother that protect them
against the disease so if these children
are infected early on they're protected
but they become they make their own
immune response and become immune to the
infection if you delay infection till
later in life when they no longer have
maternal antibodies is these begin to
decline at birth and are gone after a
few months then you will get infection
and disease so that's why we call it a
disease of modern sanitation and there's
some epidemiological data that that have
been collected over the years that
support this hypothesis the virus was
isolated by Karl Landsteiner who was
also well known for studying blood group
substances he was a Viennese physician
he isolated the virus in 1908 and what
he did was he took the spinal cord of a
boy who had died of polio he grounded up
and he filtered it this time we already
knew that there were agents called
viruses and they were defined by the
their ability to pass through a very
small filter these were porcelain
filters that were manufactured at the
time and we now know that they had a
pore size of about point 2 microns so he
found that if he filtered the extract of
spinal cord through this filter the
filter would retain bacteria and fun
I for example the viruses will pass
through you didn't take the material
that passes through with viruses in it
he inoculated into two old world monkeys
and found that they developed the
disease poliomyelitis a good thing he
used old world monkeys if he had done
this with a new world monkey wouldn't
have worked was they're not susceptible
and he would never have discovered the
virus he took these monkeys who
developed paralysis he sectioned their
spinal cord and he saw lesions just like
the lesions that can be seen in human
patients of polio so this was indication
that he passed the agent he suggested
that it was caused by a virus he was
also able to pass it from monkey too
monkey he took the monkeys who were
paralyzed ground up their spinal cords
filtered them and passed it from monkey
too monkey in fact for many years this
is how virus stocks were maintained
there were no refrigerators or freezers
at this time so to keep a virus stock
you've kept it in an animal you infected
a monkey you incubated it for a week or
two when the monkey became paralyzed you
would sacrifice it make an extract and
pass it to the next monkey and this went
on for quite a few years and in fact it
resulted in selection for some very odd
viruses with unusual properties being
passed this way from monkey too monkey
so let's take a little diversion now
look at the virus that Karl Landsteiner
discovered we're going to go into a
little biology of the virus we classify
viruses in a linnaean fashion and we put
them in families and the families are
ending in AE and so the family that
includes polio is called the peak corna
very day yeah this was a name given to
the virus many many years after its
discovery and it refers to the fact that
they're very small Pico and their
nucleic acid is RNA and now in this
family just so that you have a reference
there are a number of genera which in
turn contain different kinds of viruses
different species of viruses if you will
so here we have the enterovirus genus
which contains the polio viruses there
are also a variety of other viruses
in this enterovirus genus it was
originally named because the viruses
passed through your intestinal tract
when they infect you but a number of
years ago with the advent of nucleic
acid sequence analysis all these viruses
were reclassified and now we include in
the enterovirus genus the rhinoviruses
which are respiratory tract pathogens
this is very odd to me because
rhinovirus has nothing to do with the
enteric track so to put it in an
enterovirus genus seems odd but we are
now at the victim of the
bioinformaticians we tell us where our
viruses must be classified so that's
polio they and their many other general
in the book or no viruses with a variety
of very interesting human and animal
pathogens but that's all we'll say about
that for now these viruses are quite
small they're 30 nanometers in diameter
which is on the small side for viruses
about the smallest viruses are about 20
nanometers the biggest star over 750
nanometers and this is a photograph of
poliovirus taken in the electron
microscope you can see they are
spherical particles and they have some
surface definition that is because the
surface is irregular in 1985 the
three-dimensional structure of this
virus was determined by x-ray
crystallography so what that means is
that we could determine the position of
every atom in this capsid this is the
shell that comprises the virus in
three-dimensional space so polio viruses
are made up of four different proteins
they're called VP 1 through 4 and these
are repeated 60 times each to form this
shell this happens to be an icosahedron
which is the best kind of geometric
figure to make a virus particle of all
the solids that we know of only the
icosahedron is used to build viruses and
we think that's because it's the best
way to make a stable particle by
repeating subunits so you take three
four different viral proteins and you
repeat them 60 times you build this
icosahedron
show and that is the virus particle
which you see here and within it of
course is the nucleic acid this is shown
in green here its RNA for polio virus
and the nucleic acid of course has all
the information to make new virus
particles so this is really just a shell
it's just a carrier to bring the nucleic
acid from one post or one cell to
another now when the three-dimensional
structure of this was solved in 1985
these were the kinds of pictures that we
could make these are generated on a
computer so you have thousands of
thousands of coordinates in XYZ space
for each atom that make up this caps it
and you can build the structure it looks
something like this of course we've
taken the liberty of coloring it because
these viruses don't have color at that
size but the coloring is actually done
to pass some information on to you we
have colored this particular view of
polio in a way such that the atoms
farthest from the center of this
icosahedron are white and those closest
are black so you can see here for
example is a very high point on the
virus particle we actually call this a
plateau and around it is a very deep
part so this particle has surface
features and that's what you're seeing
in this electron micrograph right here
and in fact for polio and related
viruses this dark part this depression
which is repeated 60 times on the
particle is where the receptor binds
receptor binds into this deep depression
so we can learn a lot from these
structures we can learn where antibodies
bind that protect you against infection
we can learn how these initiate
infection to get into cell so this is
one of the first viruses to have its
structure solve in 1985 and many others
have since followed now inside that
capsid or protein shell is the nucleic
acid of the virus and that's shown
schematically here now this nucleic acid
is about 7500 bases in length the basis
of course a GC you are repeated and a
way to make up the genome and until
about nineteen eighty we had no idea
what the sequence of those bases were
this was actually my project
as a postdoctoral fellow with David
Baltimore was to determine the sequence
of that RNA and I did it by making a DNA
copy of it and taking that DNA and
putting it in a plasmid which is a
vector that will propagate in bacteria
so I could get lots and lots of DNA and
then we applied a sequencing technique
to learn the the sequence and I just
want to pass on an anecdote it took me
one year to do this sequence today I
could hand this DNA to a company in a
few hours later have the sequence of all
7440 two bases for less than a few
thousand dollars probably so one year of
my life I spent doing which now would
not be necessary for anyone to do but it
was well spent because I had good
conversations with everyone in the lab
now this RNA genome encodes all the
information to make polio and these
viruses express their genetic
information in different ways this one
makes a very long protein from this RNA
and then Cleaves it with proteinases
that are encoded by the virus so this is
the long protein here and you can see
all these cleavage sites and what you
get in the end or the individual
proteins that the virus needs to make
more virus particles so here the capsid
proteins for example and then there are
a variety of proteins involved in making
more of you playa casa de sencha lee
well that's what all these proteins do
and here's a very important protein down
here at the very end this is an enzyme
that copies the RNA makes more of it so
one RNA will get into the cell and what
comes out are thousands and thousands of
new particles so this is the sequence
that I created after one year of those
7440 two bases I can never resist
showing
what's it say year of my life so there
you have it is actually a figure I made
way back in the 80s so you can see I've
put the amino acid starting from base
742 which is where the protein initiates
is an amino acid triplet and that amino
that's the long poly protein that is
made and terminates here at the three
prime end now this is all the
information you need to make polio if
you can make this nucleic acid and drop
it into a cell that cell will make more
virus so you have to keep that in mind
when we think about eradication because
no virus will ever be really eradicated
because you can always make it again
from the sequence these sequences live
on computers they're not going anywhere
you can get this anytime from NCBI so
even if we eradicated polio someone
could make it the next day by simply
synthesizing this nucleic acid and
putting it into a cell and that's in
fact what I did next in the Baltimore
lab I took I had all these plasmids with
full-length DNA copies of the polio
genome in them and I just simply drop
them into cells in culture human cells
and culture all right and those cells
made virus so here we have polio virus
you infect cultured cells and they make
virus particles what I did was to take
the viral RNA we can extract it out of
the particle we made a DNA copy of it
that's shown down here I put that DNA
into cells just a blind experiment I
said what would happen if we put this in
cells and new viruses emerged so that's
a process called transfection and this
was an amazing result because it's the
first time it had been shown for any
animal virus but more importantly it
having a DNA copy enables you to
manipulate the virus you can change it
as you wish you could add genes you
could subtract genes you could mutate
them you can manipulate DNA you can't do
that with RNA very easily so this gave
us the ability to make different kinds
of polio viruses and now this technology
is used for all viruses and you can
create various types of viruses that
will let express different things
or so this is why I'm at Columbia
University on the basis of this nice
finding I gave a job seminar and I was
offered a position back in 1982 and I've
been there ever since and we've been
working on this using this DNA to
address a number of problems about polio
a few more things about the biology of
this virus we need to know to understand
the history I'm going to tell you this
is what happens when polio gets into a
cell so the virus is shown up here the
little icosahedron particle it binds to
a receptor on the cell surface all
viruses need to bind to receptors on
cells they don't just get in alright and
that receptor determines what cells can
be infected we actually in my lab at
columbia one of my first students Kathy
Mendelsohn actually identified and
cloned the gene encoding it and that
will be important in a moment once the
virus binds the receptor it ejects its
nucleic acid into the cytoplasm and this
is a process that's different for many
viruses but for polio the cytoplasm is
where it wants to be because it's
nucleic acid is RNA and the first step
that will happen is that this RNA is
translated into protein remember you
make that long protein and then you chop
it up to make all the individual
proteins that you need the virus also
needs to make more of its nucleic acid
and so what it does is take that that
initial RNA and it makes copies of it so
makes a copy once and then again to make
the right polarity and then these
eventually assemble with new proteins to
make new virus particles and then at
some point the cell bursts open the cell
dies and a new crop of viruses is
ejected and this for polio takes about
six to eight hours it's a very quickly
replicating virus and that is consistent
with it causing an acute infection in
people one that progresses very rapidly
now what does this do in people so this
virus causes poliomyelitis this is a
disease we acquire when we ingest the
virus so we show it here here are free
virus particles you ingest them
and they can replicate in the epithelial
cells that line your element alimentary
tract so this is an enterica iris it can
replicate in your upper alimentary tract
or can make its way into the intestines
and replicate there as well so the virus
can pass through your stomach which of
course is acidic you can pass through
the small intestine which is alkaline in
the very beginning and it has no problem
whatsoever it is incredibly resistant
and so this is one of the reasons why
this is so easily transmitted in nature
is that is a physically very resilient
virus particle so the virus enters these
cells and your mucosal surfaces in your
alimentary tract than it reproduces in
them following the scheme that I just
showed you it enters those cells makes
more virus particles then those cells
are destroyed as the viruses replicate
in these cells they are shed into your
intestines and eventually pass into the
feces all right and that is how viruses
spread from one person to another bite
what we call fecal-oral contamination so
somehow the virus and the feces gets
into the mouth of someone else and
children are very apt to do this when
they're playing or not not being very
hygienic and and that's one of the main
ways that the virus is transmitted in
addition as the virus is multiplying in
these cells it also gets into your
bloodstream as it destroys these cells
it can go beneath the mucosal layer and
just beneath here there are lymph
capillaries which are very permeable
they can tape up the virus the virus
travels from the lymph system into the
blood and establishes what we call a
very Mia that is presence of virus in
the blood so shortly after infection you
have virus in your bloodstream when
viruses are into your blood they can get
anywhere and that's not a good thing
poliovirus doesn't end up everywhere it
ends up in only a few places and one of
them is unfortunately very serious it's
the central nervous system from the
blood the virus gets into the spinal
cord and eventually the brain where it
does damage many viruses in fact can't
get into the central nerve
system it's a rare event and for that
reason the cns isn't terribly well
protected our immune system has not
developed to the same extent there as it
has elsewhere in our body because we
have very few pathogens that can get in
but polio is one of them that can get in
West Nile virus is another one when
these viruses do get in they cause big
problems so polio enters this is the
central nervous system we think it might
enter through muscles and be transported
by nerves up to the spinal cord but of
course in the spinal cord there are a
variety of cell types the most important
one our motor neurons the ones that
control your muscle activity and those
are the ones that polio virus replicates
in it kills them and as a consequence
you become paralyzed and typically you
have lower limb paralysis with polio not
always but typically and that is a
consequence of the destructions of
neurons in the lower portions of your
spinal cord but there are other forms of
polio as well in which other neurons are
destroyed throughout the spinal cord so
humans are the only known reservoir of
this virus as far as we can tell no
other animal in the wild has it we don't
know where it actually came from and
even if it's been around since the
ancient Egyptians we we don't know where
it came from an animal of some kind
there are no precursors to give us any
clues but this is important because it's
one of the requirements for eradication
of a virus infection that there's only a
human reservoir as I said it's spread by
fecal oral transmission so poor
sanitation will spread this very readily
iffy and as I said earlier if you
improve sanitation then you delay
infection to later years these
infections peak in temperate climates
during warm months in tropical climates
they tend to occur throughout the year
but in climates such as we have here in
the US in the summer time was the
typical time to have outbreaks of polio
and of course that's when the kids are
outside playing and one of the reactions
was to keep kids inside during the
summer months to try and stem magazine
there's very one very well known
complication it's called post-polio
syndrome this happens about 30 to 40
years after the initial paralysis so
there is a certain fraction of
individuals who get polio who died but
many of them have limb paralysis only
and can survive and with physical
therapy they can be rehabilitated to the
point of gaining their limb function and
in many of these individuals 30 to 40
years later they begin to experience
paralysis of the same limbs again and
that's post-polio syndrome happens in
about 20 to 25 to 40 percent of those
individuals who originally had polio it
is not an infectious process as far as
we can tell it's not a matter of virus
being in there all those years and
somehow being reactivated we're not sure
what the cause is one of the
possibilities is that the initial
incident capote lee the bout of polio
destroyed a number of motor neurons in
your body and as you age you lose more
and you don't have sufficient numbers to
innervate the muscle but we are still we
still have in this country a number of
individuals with post polio because we
had many many cases of polio and in the
40s and even in the 50s it's only until
those individuals have died will this
cease to be an issue now this is a
chronology of polio infection that I
want to go over with you to give you a
flavor for what happens with this
disease this is from a 1950s textbook of
Medicine it's a hand drawn figure which
I find very charming you don't find
these many more in science and it takes
the course of a polio infection we have
days here on the top the phase of
infection and what's going on in terms
of temperature virus in various places
and also virus in the cns so let's let's
track this through and this will help us
understand the disease so here we have
exposure to the virus starting here for
the first seven days or so you're well
there's no sign that anything
is going on and then after about a week
or so that can vary of course you have a
spike in temperature here you have
headaches sore throat nausea these are
systemic symptoms they could be almost
any virus infection they could be flu in
fact so you can't really tell that this
is polio at the same time you have virus
in your throat you can see the rise of
virus in throat secretions it's this
curve and here's a virus throat
secretions here virus in the feces so
very early on when you have these
initial symptoms you have virus in your
throat and feces so you're already
shedding virus but no one knows that you
have polio this is very important
because this is how its spread so
effectively there's no way to know that
a person coughing with a sore throat has
a polio infection until much later and
by then the virus has spread to others
at this time when you have this initial
systemic bout you have virus in the
blood you see there's a peek here it
peaks and then goes down okay so in most
of the cases 99 out of 100 cases that is
the end of the infection you will
recover and you will never know you had
polio unless you look for antibodies to
the virus which you can find later in
the serum but in about one out of a
hundred or maybe 200 infections the
virus somehow gets its way into the
central nervous system remember it goes
from your intestine to the blood into
the cns and this bottom graph is virus
in the cns and then at some point you
start to develop stiffness and pain and
paralysis and that is the typical
poliomyelitis you can have paralysis of
the leg muscles as I've said you can
also have respiratory muscles which is a
more severe problem and also paralysis
of nerves that innervate your heart as
well and that could be failed so it's a
very rare invasion of the CNS and that's
why that original individual medan in
the 1800's said he thought that the
paralysis was a complication because it
wasn't very common now in our lab and
when i started my lab at columbia in
1982 i want to study this disease i had
spent three years sequencing polio
and studying it in cell culture but I
was really interested in this disease as
you can imagine I had read about it
actually met Albert Sabin who developed
front of the vaccines I wanted to
understand how this disease develop but
there was no way to do this because the
virus only infects people or chimpanzees
and I couldn't afford chimpanzees and I
didn't really want to work on
chimpanzees anyway so I said who we get
a mouse to be a model for polio so I
told you earlier one of my first
students had identified the cell
receptor for polio so this is a protein
on the surface of cells to which polio
attaches and that lets the virus get in
and we had found that if we took this
receptor and put it on mouse cells that
we were growing in a culture dish now
these mouse cells if you put polio on
them nothing happens the virus doesn't
get in but we found if we put this human
receptor into those mouse cells the
virus would then get in and replicate
and kill the mouse cells so I was very
young and naive and I said let's do this
in a mouse afterwards years later people
told me that was a really bold
experiment but at the time I just
thought it would be interesting to try
so we made what was called a transgenic
mouse we took the gene encoding this
receptor we put it into the chromosomes
of mice so that all the mice born
subsequently would have this gene and
then we infect then with polio and you
can see they develop paralysis this
mouse here as a paralyzed left hind limb
beautiful recapitulation of the disease
in fact here is a section of the spinal
cord from one of these paralyzed mice
this is a lumbar section so it's lower
down the spinal cord innervating the
lower limbs and what we have done here
well first of all before I show you
where the virus is see all this is
stained in a certain way to emphasize
the presence of specific cells you can
see there are large clumps of cells here
and here and here these are actually
immune cells coming into the spinal cord
to try and get rid of the infection so
this spinal cord is infected and we can
tell that it's infected not only by the
presence of these immune cells which you
would never see in an uninfected mouse
but also from these green dots here and
what we have done here is we have
stained this section with a probe that
will detect viral RNA so all these green
dots are polio virus RNA multiplying in
these cells these happen to be neurons
we can tell because they're very large
and they are pyramidal in shape and that
is where polio virus is replicating are
many other cell types in the spinal cord
but polio doesn't replicate in them only
the neurons and only the motor neurons
and that's why you get paralysis so in
this mouse model you can inject the
virus say into the tail vein or
intraperitoneally it will make its way
to the spinal cord it will destroy
neurons and that's why the mouse is
hyndland was paralyzed so we could use
this model to study all sorts of
questions about polio how it caused
disease how it traveled in the mouse and
we also use it to study Albert Saban's
polio vaccines which we'll get to in a
moment and these were the these were the
vaccines that were used to eradicate
polio in the US and are now being used
in the eradication campaign in the rest
of the world so it was a very fruitful
model for us to develop and i have to
tell you just two days ago I destroyed
the remainder of this colony in my lab
no one else is interested in my lab and
working on them any longer it's an
expense to keep mice so they're now gone
we worked on for 22 years and they're no
longer around okay let's get back to
polio history and now move to larger and
larger epidemics the first big one in
New York City in 1916 not just in New
York but in the Northeast nine thousand
paralytic cases in New York City 27,000
total in the Northeast and remember you
have to multiply this times a hundred to
find the total people infected because
only one in 100 or 200 people are
actually paralytic you have a lot of
people walking around who are shedding
virus that have some cold like disease
but they're not paralyzed and that's why
the again why the infection spreads so
readily
in this epidemic is this the practice of
quarantine II was used this was
something that was developed in the
preceding years and they said well if
you have someone who's paralyzed we're
going to put them in quarantine so they
can't infect anyone else in at this time
that was realized to be futile because
during this epidemic we learned that in
fact most people who are infected with
the virus don't show paralysis so
there's no point in quarantine the
paralyzed individuals because there are
for everyone there are 99 walking around
who are actually shedding the virus this
is a problem with many virus infections
not all a smallpox for example every
infected case shows symptoms and that's
one of the reasons why you could
eradicate it the way they did which was
to find a case and then do ring
immunization in that area but you can't
do that with polio because you can't see
everyone who is infected and that will
return later as an issue in polio
eradication so from this epidemic we had
four conclusions first of all it's
exclusively a human infection there was
no evidence for any other animal being
involved it's far more prevalent than
apparent from clinically recognized
cases okay one in 100 or 200 paralytic
cases per total infected and these
asymptomatic in mild cases so
asymptomatic no symptoms or the mild
ones that is the systemic sore throat
cough etc those are the most important
in spreading the disease as a
consequence if you have an epidemic
where you have one or one two three
cases per a thousand people this will
immunize the general population that's
why epidemics are self-limiting because
you have enough infection without
disease that the virus is spreading to
everyone and it basically immunizes
everyone so every polio epidemic is
self-limiting and it will only occur
again when you have enough susceptibles
in the population so these are very
important lessons learned now many of
the photos of polio from those arrows
show people in iron lungs there are many
many books on the history of polio this
is a very popular topic to write about
it was a very scary and prevalent as
in the u.s. these you don't find any
more but when individuals have had polio
paralysis of the respiratory muscle
they're put into these iron lungs which
did the breathing for them and most of
them could come out there are a few
individuals who were in these for their
entire lives though there was an
incidence a few years ago a woman who
had been in since the 1940s and she died
in the iron law but hospitals now no
longer have these of course but very
common photos now one of our presidents
Franklin Roosevelt of course is believed
to have polio which is another
remarkable thing I believe in that the
US president being elected with the
paralytic disease of course wouldn't
happen today but back then there was no
internet not much television and so it
was possible he of course wanted to find
a solution to the disease so he started
the March of Dimes which raised money
and eventually that money was used to
develop polio vaccines and along the way
it took many years to make a polio
vaccine this is a good lesson actually
so the virus was isolated in 1908 and
the first vaccine that worked was
released in 1954 to 50 years to make a
vaccine because we had to learn a lot of
things before we could make a good
vaccine not that people didn't try
people did try to make vaccines but they
didn't work so here are some of the
milestones in leading to a vaccine 1931
the isolation of polio from throat
washings of people who were not
paralyzed at the throat and people again
realizing that this could be spread from
people who didn't have paralytic disease
1941 isolation of virus from the pharynx
the ileum and the nervous system of
people with polio but not from the nose
the olfactory bulbs for many years
people thought that this virus was
spread from the nose to the nose someone
else the virus entered the nose and
entered your brain through the nose and
that was incorrect 1947 virus was
isolated from sewage which told us that
it was probably passed by fecal-oral
roots and fine
in 1954 the defining a virus in the
blood again all this is a contributor to
the pathogenesis which I have told you a
big discovery in 1949 by John Enders and
colleagues being able to grow the virus
in cultures of human cells from non
nervous tissues so the first growth of a
virus of any kind in a cell culture and
we place the monkey from detecting and
propagating polio and this allowed us to
grow a vaccine you can't grow vaccines
and animals so we needed a cell culture
and this was the key discovery they got
the Nobel Prize for that in 1954 a study
of Arctic Eskimos showed that a single
subclinical infection that is without
paralysis gave you immunity which would
last for at least 40 years so that said
we can make a vaccine we can if we can
make antibodies then we can protect
people from polio and finally in 1951
just a few years before the vaccine was
released we learned that there are three
serotypes of polio now a Sarah type
means that if you make an antibody
against one Sarah type those antibodies
will protect you against that but not of
two other any other serotypes that may
exist so if people didn't know this
earlier that there were three serotypes
of polio and they would make a vaccine
against one Sarah type and then the
other two serotypes would come in in
quaaz polio so this was a very important
find the first vaccine to be released
was inactivated polio vaccine or ipv
this virus was grown in cells using John
Enders methods and its infectivity
destroyed by treating it with
formaldehyde or formal in so this
destroys the virus particles so it
cannot be infectious and that was
developed by Jonas Salk it was subjected
to a clinical trial in 1954 the National
Foundation for infantile paralysis the
March of Dimes founded by FDR funded
this clinical trial 1,800,000 children
the biggest-ever medical clinical trial
in kids the vaccine was fifty percent
protective it was
least these data were released i equal
12 1955 and the vaccine was licensed on
the same day so this was met with great
fanfare in the US and here are some of
the headlines from New York newspapers
at the time which show that this this
disease was a big deal and these are all
the papers they used to exist here in
New York I guess with the exception the
post in the mirror the only other times
are the only one left I remember all of
these when I was a kid however this is
an interesting coda hear that shortly
after these virus this vaccine was
released within 10 days kids who got it
started to develop paralysis all right
and that was eventually linked back to
the vaccine itself eventually it was
determined that 200,000 people were
infected by this vaccine 70,000 became
ill there were two hundred sixty vaccine
associated cases in 94 immunized kids in
166 contacts of that and a number of
deaths as well the reason why it
happened is that one of the companies
who had made the vaccine there were a
number in the US who are licensed by the
FDA to produce the vaccine one of the
company's called cutter laboratories in
California hadn't properly inactivated
the virus with formaldehyde so they
actually sold vaccine with infectious
virus in it this is injected into the
kids arm and they got paralyzed I can
you imagine here you're a parent waiting
for this vaccine and you bring your kid
to get immunized and then ten days later
they're paralyzed so this is very sad
this according to Paul Offit is the
beginning of the anti-vaccine movement
in the US because a huge lawsuit
resulted as a consequence of this and
the lawsuit established product
liability that no matter what a
manufacturer does if someone gets hurt
someone has to be liable for that it's a
very interesting case in fact Paul Offit
wrote a very good book about this called
the cutter incident nevertheless it was
restored and corrected and returned to
use in the US polio fell from twenty
twenty thousand cases a year to 2500 by
1960 but many people felt that this
vaccine was not the one
is going to eliminate polio from the US
they felt that we needed a vaccine that
would mimic a natural infection and
there was some data to support this
Hilary koprowski and John Enders in the
early 50s showed that if you took polio
it just passed it in cell culture from
cell culture to cell culture you could
make viruses that had reduced virulence
and animals so the model used to study
polio in these years was the monkey
various types of old world monkeys and
they could show just by growing the
virus in cell culture that the virus
would be less lethal for animals so
Albert Sabin took advantage of these
observations and he developed what we
now call the oral polio vaccine or opv
Saban's vaccine and of course he made
all three serotypes as did Jonas Salk
because that's what you need to protect
these vaccines were licensed in 1961
Saban had a hard time getting them
licensed in the US because we had the
Salk vaccine already and the US Public
Health Service said we don't need
another vaccine so Sabin went to the
Soviet Union which existed at the time
he had a friend there it come from
Soviet Union originally he was born
there and he had a friend called
chumakov who was that father of Soviet
virology and he convinced him to do a
clinical trial with his strains they put
it in a hundred million kids and Sabin
came back with the results and got his
vaccine licensed very interesting story
he carried out what were called Sabin
Sunday's community-wide administration
of his vaccine even though still until
the 80s only sixty to seventy percent of
kids were getting the three doses so in
the beginning you would give type 1
first then type 2 and then type 3 so you
had to have the kids come back three
times which is very difficult you're
never going to get one hundred percent
vaccination when you have to keep coming
back so not everyone was getting
immunized eventually it was incorporated
into routine vaccination program for
young children so now you have to be
immunized in order to go to school and
that brought cases from 2500 when only
ipv was used to zero in 1979 I was a
last indigenous case of polio
in the US so those are the two vaccines
that were made we still have both of
them you can use either one in depending
on the country that you're in we have
inactivated vaccine this is an injected
vaccine by the way so you need a trained
health care person to do it if you make
it right it doesn't give you polio since
the nineteen fifty incident it's been
fine it doesn't give you immunity in
your intestine it's injected into your
arm gives you antibodies in your blood
but you could still in jest polio and
that would replicate in your intestine
it would get into your blood and then it
would hit those antibodies and be
neutralized but you could still excrete
polio okay the reason I say this is
because the US now is using only ipv so
the collective elementary tracts of
Americans are susceptible to polio so if
a strain came into the US it could
replicate in our guts and perhaps spread
to someone who wasn't immunized so we
used ipv until nineteen sixty one and
then we started using it again in two
thousand and we'll talk about why opv is
very easy to administer you just drink
it you don't need any doctor or nurse to
do that you get intestinal immunity
because it grows it replicates in your
gut and these are made of viruses that
albert sabin empirically derived from
wild-type virus will talk about that and
a very important point it usually
reverts in the intestine as it
replicates and we will talk a lot about
that and we use this from nineteen sixty
one to two thousand and two thousand we
switched to ipv so how do these vaccines
work again you ingest polio it goes into
your alimentary tract where it
replicates opv will block the virus from
replicating in the epithelium of your
alimentary tract ipv will not it will
only block virus once it enters the
blood so two very different vaccines and
this is the effect on polio in the US
here at the number of cases annually
twenty to thirty thousand in the US
introduction of the inactivated vaccine
caused the precipitous decline in a
number of cases and then we brought in
the Sabin vaccine in 1961
case in 1979 we have no more for the
most part no polio in the US with a few
exceptions nevertheless even though we
had two really good polio vaccines and
in developing countries most of the kids
didn't get them for a variety of reasons
and so there was still a lot of global
polio even by the 1980s when we had
eradicated it from the US now Sabin went
to Brazil at this time and he instituted
mass immunization campaigns which he
called national immunization days and he
showed that you could eradicate polio in
a country like Brazil by just two
immunizations and as a result of his
work in Brazil the wh 0 established this
expanded program on immunization and
they said we're going to help increase
the use and distribution of polio
vaccine worldwide and it's really
because of Sabin and wh 0 taking this
initiative that we're at the point where
we are today so here is the data from
Brazil these are the incidents of polio
cases in Brazil before immunization
these are the number of cases here and
you can see he did twice a year june in
august every year and eventually got rid
of polio in brazil very important so the
wh 0 eventually decided that they could
eradicate polio and i think you've heard
about this in this series before they
made a resolution in 1988 and the idea
would be eradication would occur by 2005
and then at some point we would stop
immunizing because you don't want to
keep immunizing for a disease that
doesn't exist so here we are in 2012 and
we still have polio so let's look at why
and how that relates to the biology of
the virus so here's the incidence
globally of polio 1988 600,000 reported
cases globally probably vastly
underreported much lower in 1988 1998
and in 2008 and I'll show you the
statistics today less than a thousand
cases per year so here are the
challenges to eradicating this virus now
we still have transmission of wild
viruses that is that are out there in
certain places we have at a complication
that we didn't predict
they're called vaccine derived polio
viruses will talk about that we have
persistence of vaccine virus in people
without antibodies and then we have
reinfection of previously polio-free
areas so we're going to touch on some of
those in the next few minutes so how did
save and make his vaccines important for
us to understand this and this is an
example of the type three component
remember their three serotypes type 3
was isolated from a fatal case in Los
Angeles in 1937 Sabin took this he
passed it extensively in monkey so
passage means you infect the monkey the
monkey gets paralyzed you grind up the
spinal cord you make an extract you pass
it to the next monkey this 21 times here
then he passed it in monkey testicle
cultures monkey kidney cultures 39 3 so
he disc kept passing it and passing it
until he got viruses that would no
longer kill monkeys when he put them
right in the spinal cord so it's an
empirical process he eventually got
vaccine strains that actually worked and
here's one of them he did this for all
three serotypes and then when he had
them all this was nineteen fifty why do
you think the first thing he did with
them was you think he got IRB approval
to do something you know what I RB is
right institutional review board but do
you think he did he ate them exactly he
drank them actually gave to his wife and
daughter as well as himself they're all
seropositive because they had gotten
antibodies by in apparent infections but
he tested him on himself that's the way
it was done those things then he gave it
who did he give it to next prisoners
volunteer prisoners and then he moved
into larger clinical trials and
eventually the Soviet Union a hundred
million kids and that's how it got
license but today of course you don't do
that so when I started working on polio
we had the ability to sequence the
genome first time in the nineteen eighty
so we could say let's take what Albert
Sabin made and sequence it and compare
it to what he started with and see what
are the changes so he did that there
were many many changes from the virulent
to the attenuated virus that is the
vaccine
virus but then we took my mouse model
for polio and we put the changes in one
by one into the virulent virus and said
which one of these make it a good
vaccine we did that for many years and
other people did it in monkeys and this
is the result of that for all three
serotypes these are the mutations in the
genome that Albert Sabin selected for
which are very important for making
these good vaccine strains so these
don't mean a lot to you you can see the
type one has five changes and then the
type 2 and 3 have two changes that make
it a good vaccine just two so we didn't
know this when Saban's vaccines were
licensed because if we knew it they
would never have been licensed today if
you try to license a vaccine a live
attenuated vaccine with two changes out
of 7,500 the FDA would say come back
when you have that in a hundred or 50 or
it's more stable but we didn't know that
and technology you gave us the ability
to know this so very few changes make
Albert Sabin vaccine work well I want to
show you where some of these are you see
all three viruses have a change in what
I've labeled utr this means untranslated
region this is a part of the RNA that is
not translated into protein and its way
at the very end of the RNA so remember
the schematic of the RNA of the virus
there's all this green part in the
middle codes for protein the very end
here we call this the five prime end it
has an untranslated region it's orange
it's not translated into protein that's
where those mutations that Albert Sabin
selected for are located in this very
interesting region that has a lot of RNA
structure and you can see they're all in
the same area this is the change in the
type 1 virus the type to in the type 3
and this is amazing to me because he
selected these viruses separately in
monkeys but they all end up having a
similar mutation in a very very
neighboring part of the genome all right
so this is it this is probably the most
important mutation in all these strains
that make his virus not virulent when
you drink it that's important to
remember so in my lab we had made these
mice susceptible to polio so what we did
is we infected
em with two different polio viruses and
one of them has a base at 472 that's in
that five prime UTR to you that's the
base that was in Saban's polio vaccine
the other virus has AC at that position
that is the base and the virus that
saved and started with that's the virial
and face if you will if you inject so
these two viruses are identical for
7,000 and 440 nucleotides except for
this one based difference if you put
them in mice this one doesn't do
anything to the mice you can put as much
virus as possible that you can eject
none get paralyzed they're fine if you
put in the sea if you put 9,000
infectious viruses into them half the
mice get paralyzed so this is quite
lethal and just changing one base makes
a big difference so this is an
incredibly important base and this is
why when we drink the Sabin vaccine
we're not paralyzed if you look at the
growth of this virus with time in the
brain of these animals so they look
measuring virus here and we're measuring
it with time you see the virus is with
you you don't really grow they
eventually are cleared from the cns so
those are the ones that don't cause
paralysis in contrast the virus with the
sea grows very well in mice and that's
why it paralyzes them so this just
emphasizes the importance of this base
change and this is going to come back to
haunt us in a moment now in the 1950s
when Saban was first testing his
vaccines in his first volunteers what he
would do he would feed some volunteers
his candidate vaccines and then he would
collect what came out in the feces and
then he would study that and what he
found was that and others found that
some people who received these opvs they
excreted viruses that were more neuro
virulent than what he put in new
virulent meaning causing paralysis and
monkeys so that was the first clue that
something was going on with these
viruses as they replicated in D in the
individuals when his vaccines were
licensed in
60s they were cases of polio associated
with type 3 vaccine in Eastern Europe in
the early 60s and we now know these were
caused by the vaccine itself so very
early on we knew that Saban's vaccine
would cost polio and as we eliminated
indigenous polio from the US that is
polio caused by circulating virus the
only paralysis left was caused by the
vaccine we call this vaccine associated
paralytic polio or vApp and it occurred
at a rate of about seven to eight every
year in the US that it's about a rate of
one per 1.4 million doses of vaccine so
for every 1.4 million kids who got the
polio vaccine one of them would be
paralyzed or sometimes the parent would
be paralyzed by the virus excreted from
the child now as a result we switched to
Salk's vaccine in two thousand so there
was no more polio in the US after 1979
except polio caused by the vaccine so
you can imagine this was a intelligent
public health decision by this time of
course Jonas Salk had died so he didn't
get to see his vaccine resuscitated
again but we switched to ipv4 that
reason because opv savings virus which
had eliminated wild polio in the US was
causing a paralytic disease so here is a
detailed view of the cases of polio in
the u.s. from 1961 to 2003 here's an
overall view you see going from 10,000
in the mid-50s the introduction of ipv
and then in 1961 opv and eventually
eradication now let's blow up this
shaded portion and we'll look here
starting in 1961 total cases is shown by
the line and vaccine associated cases by
the bars the dark bars so you can see
here there were a number of vaccine
associated cases but they are
overshadowed by the wild polio but as
you eliminate wild polio you see the
only polio in the u.s. is now caused by
the vaccine 1973 576 every case
then on is caused by the vaccine except
for 1979 this was an outbreak in an
unvaccinated Amish community in
Pennsylvania this was virus that had
been imported from Turkey so after that
point there is no more wild polio in the
US so in two thousand we switched to ipv
now zero polio in the US although there
was recently a case at which we'll talk
about later now why is this happening
why does polio vaccine cause polio I've
given you some clues but let's look at
some more data in 1985 fill miner a
friend of mine from the UK he worked for
the FDA equivalent in the UK he was
responsible for testing and release of
polio vaccine he had a baby and the baby
received polio vaccine and he was aware
of the work I've just told you where we
identified the mutations in the vaccine
strains that made them good vaccines and
so he said is it possible that these are
changing in the gut and can we pick it
up so after his child was immunized he
had his wife give him every diaper that
the child produced for the first month
or so of life and he brought it into the
lab and he scraped off the feces and
isolated polio and sequenced it it's
called the nappy experiment famous in
virology and he published in nature
paper based on this in 1985 so here is
the here the data his son is DM David
minor and on day 24 after immunization
the virus that David was excreting it's
polio vaccine virus it has a you at 472
that's the base that's very important
for making it a safe vaccine that's the
one that I studied in mice and I showed
you before now the vaccine of course
also has a you so that's good dm2 at 31
hours stila you very good but look at 35
hours it's now virus with a mixture of
you and see at 472 and by 47 hours two
days after receiving the polio vaccine
orally David minor is excreting virus
the sea which as you know and mice will
paralyze the mice and that he does for
the rest of he excreted this for about a
month and you can see that these viruses
are virulent so the way we measure polio
virulence we could of course look at
paralysis in an animal or you can take
the spinal cord and look for lesions
caused by polio that is killing of cells
by polio replication that's where this
histological lesion score is it's very
low for the vaccine but you can see as
with increasing time David was excreting
virus of increased virulence so these
two lesions scores would cause this to
fail the FDA tests for being released as
a vaccine okay so he's excreting very
very land virus but David minor was fine
and in fact this happens in every kid
that gets polio vaccine after two or
three days they excrete reverted virus
that is fully variant most of them are
fine but one in 1.4 million or not they
get paralytic disease and this is why
because in your gut you select for
viruses with AC the sea viruses which
contaminate the vaccine prep you can't
avoid it they are selected for they grow
better and within just two days they
dominate the population so that is a
problem if you are using this vaccine to
eradicate polio so polio vaccine i think
you will recognize is very different
from smallpox because the polio vaccine
can revert to cause the disease it's
meant to prevent smallpox doesn't do
that smallpox vaccine is very different
from smallpox virus it doesn't revert to
cause smallpox so when we use opv to
eradicate which is what we're doing now
the only source of polio is the vaccine
once you get rid of wild virus like we
did in the US after 1979 and that's why
woho in 1988 said we're going to stop
immunizing at some point when we
eradicate polio because we don't want to
have vaccine associated polio the
assumption there was that all of those
vaccine derived strains which you
generated by immunizing millions in
of kids who then excreted those reverted
viruses into the sewers the assumption
is that they will not last very long
they will go away so you could stop
immunizing and they would not pose a
threat to any new babies who were born
and weren't immunized ok that was the
assumption wh 0 made and they turned out
to be very wrong about that and the
reason was they were in the 90s a number
of outbreaks in a variety of countries
starting the Dominican Republic Haiti
but also in Egypt Philippines Madagascar
all outbreaks caused by vaccine derived
polio viruses these were in areas where
immunization coverage dropped so there
wasn't much polio it was failure to
immunize sufficient numbers of people
and the virus somehow got into these
populations and cause outbreaks but it
was vaccine derived virus we can tell
that very easily we sequence it we can
see that saban derive so these are
vaccine drive viruses that regain
virulence as I've told you what happened
to fill miner his virus that he
excavated and they also can spread in
human populations in addition we have
many people in the world who have
immunodeficiencies in particular people
who lack b-cells they can't make
antibodies you can't tell that they lack
antibodies at birth so shortly after
birth you give them polio vaccine they
can excrete it for years it's been
documented that these individuals will
excrete polio up to 15 years it's
another reservoir of infection and in
fact many of these strains have come
from immunocompromised people to cause
these outbreaks and in these areas and
so this is a summary of some of these
outbreaks first one is in Dominican
Republic Haiti 21 cases in july of 2000
so you can isolate virus from these
individuals you can sequence it and then
you can say how many years it's been
circulating in humans because polio
changes when polio is circulating in the
population it changes at a rate of one
percent a year it has a very steady
clock so you can count the number of
changes in any isolate that you get
compare it to the save and strain
and say how many years his virus has
been circulating so here you can see
this the virus that caused this outbreak
in Hispaniola circulated for two years
before it caused the outbreak and it's
thought that this came from an
immunocompromised person who was
harboring the virus for many many years
now there are 21 cases of paralytic
disease but remember the number of
infections is much greater and in this
case it was estimated to be one to two
hundred thousand total people infections
so 21 cases may not seem like much but
you always have to remember that there
are many many more people infected and
they can spread the virus to other
people as well so even today if we have
one case of polio in India so far this
year which is the case there could be a
hundred or a thousand people infected
with the virus still and these are all
other outbreaks that have occurred
similar idea of virus circulating for
many years causing an outbreak in under
immunized populations while vaccine
derived isolates right so this trash is
the wh 0 idea that we can stop
immunizing because they assume that all
these vaccine derived viruses would go
away the day you stop immunizing but
they don't they circulate for years so
you can't just stop immunizing and this
is an interesting case in the US which I
wrote about not too long ago this is a
case of polio just recently and this is
a woman who died of polio in Minnesota
44 years old she went to the hospital
with symptoms of muscle pain and
paralysis she was in the hospital for
three months eventually died during her
stay in the hospital they had no clue
what was wrong with her but eventually
they isolated polio from her and
sequenced it and calculated that she had
been harboring it for 12 years so this
woman has no antibodies she's b-cell
deficient and she probably got this
virus when her kid got polio vaccine 12
years ago and she got the virus
replicated in her for 12 years and then
for some reason recently went into her
CNS and caused paralysis now these
individuals get weekly injections of
antibodies to protect them against
fection but this didn't help her so
apparently she got Colin I so this is an
example of what can happen with these
immunodeficient individuals they can
Harbor virus for a long period and if
there are people around her that are not
immunized they can be infected as well
so what this means to summarize that
these outbreaks show that these strains
of OPV can circulate even in immune
populations and many of those outbreaks
they were circulating in immune
populations and as I said if you stop
this mimics what would happen if you
stop immunizing you're going to have
circulation of these revertants which
will infect new children who aren't
immunized so I don't think you can stop
immunizing as wh 0 that originally
proposed so we after we eradicate polio
you have to immunize against opv
essentially I think you have to switch
to the Salk vaccine globally until all
the circulating vaccine derived viruses
go away now this is a problem because I
PV costs more than OPV OPV you can make
for about five cents a dose and I PV is
about a bucket dose but we can just get
more money from from bill gates at Al
real problem is that these inactivated
vaccines have not really been shown to
be effective in certain tropical
underdeveloped countries so it's a bit
of an experiment we may have to develop
about a vaccine that is in fact better
but I think this makes the most sense to
switch to ipv and then you have to
monitor the environment to be able to
know when there's no more circulating
vaccine derived polio present and so
there's a good example of this was done
in New Zealand they switched from opv to
ipv in 2002 and they monitor the
presence of polio in three different
sewage treatment plants in the country
so here we have % positives for polio
virus with time starting in 2002 through
2003 so you can see that the amount of
vire OPV is a circulating vaccine drive
virus within a year basically declines
there's still a little background this
is an imported opv so they could take
this virus and sequence it and say
it's opv and we haven't used OPV and
since the previous year so it was
probably important and eventually you
detect no virus so this is what I would
propose globally you switch the opv ipv
and then monitor the environment for the
presence of vaccine derive viruses and
at some point you have to make a
decision we stopped immunizing I don't
know who will make that decision but
it's a it's a pretty important one to do
so I number of years ago forget when
this was early 90s perhaps I was at a
meeting in the National Academy and I
spoke about this whole issue and I said
we should switch to ipv and da Henderson
was there and I think he talked to you
in this series and he got up and he said
so we have then say seven or eight years
whatever it is to gear up to the vaccine
then another ten years to use
inactivated this is just totally
unrealistic we are not going to have the
financial support globally for this
there's no way it's going to come about
and as an end game strategy it is
dreaming to believe that this is
reasonable so it is just not on so I was
surprised because da Henderson
eradicated smallpox so he must know
right but now the wh 0 has decided that
we need to transition to ipv so it's
going to happen somehow so the moral is
that when someone speaks forcefully
always look for what is behind that I
think so da Henderson now says yeah we
have to use ipv but when I got up and
suggest that if you said it's not going
to happen I thought that would be
interesting to hear since he did talk to
you guys ok so what are the problems do
you have you have vaccine derived polio
viruses you have reintroduction or you
have reintroduction coupled with
governments not wanting to immunize 9th
2003 rumors of contaminated opv which is
made in the West led the Government of
Nigeria to suspend immunizations that we
don't trust this so for one year they
didn't immunize any kid so what happened
there was still wild polio in the world
it was an outbreak spread and it not
only did the virus I think it came from
Indonesia and India to Nigeria had many
many cases of polio in Nigeria and then
spread to neighboring countries in
Africa
where they had already eliminated polio
as a consequence so 3 and 3 outside
Africa as well so they've decided a year
later to start immunization but we still
have endemic polio in Nigeria 388 cases
in 2009 and so far this year just 17 but
remember multiply it by a hundred at
least for the number of infections now
this to continue this interesting story
this is another example of the
complications we have in 1999 wh 0 said
there's no more type to polio globally
it's eradicated so when nigeria started
to resume immunization in 2004 they used
a vaccine with just type 1 and type 3
components so what do you think happened
I'm sorry I didn't hear it what what
happened the type to operate caused by
what where did the type to virus come
from not where but what kind of our
vaccine derived type 2 right so you
should not have switched overs another
example of what happens if you stop
immunizing they're circulating vaccine
derived polio you can't stop unless you
make sure they are not there so vaccine
derive type 2 caused this outbreak in
Nigeria so you really can't consider
type to eradicate it if there's still
vaccine derive type 2 and it's still
used in some parts of the world the type
to OPV so here's the situation at the
moment I will wrap it up very quickly
2011 I just got these data yesterday you
can go to polio eradication org and you
get daily numbers on the eradication
effort so these are all the countries in
yellow where we still have polio the
ones with solid yellow we call the
endemic countries we have never gotten
rid of polio from these countries
Nigeria India Afghanistan and Pakistan
and then the others which have little
hatch marks these are importation
countries so these may or may not have
been free of polio at one time but then
it comes back in and the reason it comes
back in is because it's still present in
these other countries and global travel
brings it and do you think there's a
paralyzed person sitting on an airplane
bringing the button oh it's one of the
people who's just shedding virus but has
a cough or maybe no symptoms so that's
why it's
easy to spread so here the numbers last
year 2010 globally 1349 cases of polio
232 in endemic countries 1000 over a
thousand in non endemic countries these
are introduced cases from other places
so you multiply this times 100 to get
the total number of people infected so a
thousand looks like a good number but
really 134,000 people are still shedding
virus the point is you have to be
vigilant even if you get the cases down
low you have to keep going in and
immunizing massive campaigns and that
may not be so easy to do this year we
have to date 252 cases which is pretty
good 80 for an endemic 180 68 and
non-endemic so we're doing a little
better than the same time last year so
this is good it looks pretty good and
here are the numbers for all the
countries where cases of polio be
reported and I just want to point out a
couple of things here is year-to-date
2011 so India which has been one of the
toughest countries to bring down the
numbers it's been at a thousand of so
cases for the last five years suddenly
now we have one case so far in 2011 2010
22 so that's really good but the monsoon
season is now coming on and during that
time there's a lot of transmission so
we'll see what happens again remember
there are at least a hundred people
infected so you have to keep going in
and immunizing that's still a lot of
cases in Pakistan Pakistan and
Afghanistan have have a problem because
it's sometimes very difficult to get in
and immunize there's armed conflict
going on and the teams that have the
vaccine often cannot immunize kids and
so they don't get vaccine then you have
outbreaks of polio there have been some
outbreaks in Africa this year you can
see dr congo and Chad had a number of
cases these were all imported from other
places and also last year in Tajikistan
there were quite a few cases of polio
imported from India so this emphasizes
that you can get the numbers down very
low but you have to keep hammering with
the immunization you can't leave a
pockets open
but it's a problem of course if there is
a war and in places like the dr congo
there's a lot of unrest and it's very
difficult to immunize everyone so we
have a great vaccine that will
definitely eradicate but it's often hard
to do it now remember even if we
eradicate polio from the globe as long
as we have the sequence you can make it
again so I think it may be possible to
eradicate polio but we do have that
sequence that I made years ago sitting
in computers and if someone wanted to
they could make it and reintroduce it so
we have to stop pile vaccines after
eradication and be on the alert for
something happening and I want to leave
you with just one more thought what
vaccine should we stockpile after
eradication we have two choices we could
use Saban's ipv or we could use I'm
sorry Salk's ipv or saban's opv now
socks ipv is made from virulent viruses
so in an era where polio is eradicated
and no immunization is occurring growing
that virulent virus is a bsl-4
proposition that's very hard to do
production bsl-4 Sabin vaccines of
course you don't need bsl-4 but they
revert if you had an outbreak say and
gave Sabin vaccine you now reintroduce
all that vaccine derived polio into the
environment so it's not a good idea
either so this I think is a very neat
idea and what was done here this is in
the lab of eckhart Wimmer they took
polio and they took the capsid region
and they they changed every code on soco
doubt of course codes for an amino acid
they changed every coat on so it would
make the same amino acid but the
sequence was different so you know the
code has wobble so you can do that and
they can make thousands of changes in
this virus it still grows but it doesn't
kill mice it doesn't paralyze them so it
would in theory be a good vaccine and if
you have one or two thousand changes
it's probably never going to revert
because polio changes one percent a year
it's probably not enough time to get it
to revert so this would seem like the
ideal vaccine so you do this massive
change in the capsid region so this has
to be clinical trial of course and it's
not clear who would do this but this
would be an ideal kind of vaccine to
stockpile after eradication occurred all
right I think I will stop there let me
just move to one last slide that I want
to promote my educational doing so I
since hearing Stephen reading Stephen
Hawking's book I've decided I want to be
the world's virology professor so i
started i started podcasting and
blogging we now do three podcasts one on
viruses one on bacteria and one on
parasites and you can find them all at
my blog which is at virology WS I also
write periodically about what's going on
in the world of viruses so check those
out if you like viruses thank you thank
you very much please join me in thanking
this I was going to mention and thank
you for for showing that slide if you
want to keep up to date on what's going
on in virology this is a great source
and for those of you who are interested
in learning about the scientific
technical aspects i highly recommend
principles of I rolla G the book that
Professor rock and yellow co-authored as
an excellent scientific introduction to
the field so thank you very much
we'll have time for a few questions the
microphone is in place and please feel
free to ask I thank you very much for an
interesting talk you mentioned earlier
the rise of an anti-vaccine movement in
this country and what's your take on
this today because we've had our
reactions in different contexts to the
populace regarding us experimentation
the Tuskegee experiments or the atomic
soldiers etc where we at today in our
society with this so there's a growing
anti-vaccine movement which stems from a
number of sources there have been some
problems with vaccines and one of them
we pointed out here the cutter incident
began at all in the 50s other vaccines
over the years have had side effects and
these these I think when amplified and
used in the wrong hands can be used to
misinform people about the general
safety of vaccines so I think that and
couple that with the internet now and
that everyone can write whatever they
like there are many blogs which you can
find which say this vaccine is bad
because this happened and that happened
and it's all false pretty much and
people find these and they think they're
they're real and that's in part why I'm
doing this to try and counter all that
so there there's an access to
information but it's not necessarily
correct and there's a perception that I
don't have to immunize my kids they'll
be okay because there's not much virus
around anyone
so from easels for example there's not
much measles in the US so I'm not going
to get my kid give me a nice Pacific may
cause office and this is bad pockets
exist intend to do communities because
anti-vaccine videos get together that
meetings then you have susceptibility
for outbreaks of measles in the US my
take is that this is highly unfortunate
it's increasing I'm not sure anything I
think the president partly to blame for
it they still give credibility to wake
you first started this anti MMR years
ago CNN recently at him on instead
controversy continues there's no
countries why do they do so CNN wants to
have
so I press over so that's the
combination this information the
internet that press
I don't see it declined
sir thank you for the talk was
fascinating you said that only one in
about a hundred infections ends up with
an infection of the cns and then
paralysis is there any information as to
what causes that and whether it's with
the virus or the host soul from let me
tell you what it is we think that there
are two main things that cause the
official effectiveness so when you first
get infected with polio it ramification
you're done gets into
but it does so it uses a very strong
interferon be produced the interference
of ucf of our feet and that limits olya
periphery so we think it one and a
hundred people those individuals
actually have a subtle off that allows
the virus to get to take mice and knock
out the innate system
then one at 100 out under infection sir
it would that lie with a general
immunodeficiency or is that or an
interaction with a different illness or
diseases it just genetic so it's not a
visa we don't have a lot of information
on what kinds of mutations there are
general population so we're starting to
learn for other infections that all the
workers interpretations interferon genes
do control susceptibility to fire
suppression so there's not enough polio
left to give these correlative studies
so we don't know what the other is that
the transport of virus from the muscles
and cns while axonal transport it's a
very specific system that we have bring
things from our muscles that CMS back
this is very slow very efficient that's
probably another reason why it's ours
doesn't get to the CMS or inefficient if
you you can stick if you stick the
person with
let's say you give a kid a deal
objection and then the next day even the
folio miss those kids are more likely to
hit by RCC is this has been known since
the Tiffany so kids went to the position
had shot one or the folio cha together
they would be more likely the reason is
when you stick a needle in a muscle you
are stimulating axonal transport those
muscles responding into a stress that
needs to get makes the cns back so that
takes up with artists will quickly so
that's the other limiting factor with
the slowness of the epitome this isn't
mice
thank you very much so earlier in your
talk you mentioned that one of the key
reasons why polio so deadly and has been
so effective and its spread is because
of this asymptomatic stage that varies
in length but is really crucial for the
spread because you really don't know
what infection someone has and it's one
to a million that it could be polio and
you really can't track it so the this
asymptomatic stage has been observed in
other viruses and it's theorized to
exist in some particularly infective
ones once that a dot that I don't have
it like smallpox for example we heard
about that but influenza for example
it's it's been not not necessarily show
him but theorize that it does exist in
that so given your experience with polio
do you think you could suggest any
biological and also policy related
measures that we could apply in
countries where this asymptomatic stages
particularly guess important for the
spread of the virus in other words to
combat this a symptomatic stage and any
effects that might have problem holyoke
surveys right house
rain shower then get a stool sample but
what about the ones that are affected I
don't know anyway you can't sample
everyone my my dreams is that in 10
years we'll have
viruses Star Trek like Laura tracks and
pine to this the google acts of
diagnostic i do this
here read outliers but that's obviously
fanciful thinking it's not going to
happen to that so the moment there's
just no way of sewage surveys but
they're only as good as that's currently
what it's not to try and get an idea of
how much virus there isn't an area but
in areas with conflict if you don't have
a sewage system
hello think before you talking in the
pharmaceutical case before that there
were no liabilities for pharmaceutical
companies there were some but it had not
evolved to the point where heroes that
the pharmaceutical company made a
brother because no matter what was done
some even was made perfectly so folio
space this was a in front but even if
you made it perfectly and it's some
virus that causes cases the company was
still alive so you can imagine all these
paralytic cases that is open come Sabin
vaccine ever any many losses any word
watch as the idea is even if made it
perfectly still have to live so if today
you get infected by something you took
from Pfizer they're liable always good
lawyer okay start with these they are
life so I was I down many of these cases
as an expert witness there's no evidence
that
properly yet most of the time
and I think I'm not a lawyer but I think
this began has been covered at City
there's monsters
so thank you one quick question i was
wondering approximately how long does
the buyer stay active once it's in extra
mint in the waste process so about how
long would stay floating around that we
would actually have to keep on
vaccinating for well
environment baby at the post six months
where is the biggest threat is within
okay let me check compromise people are
shedding and constantly they're not sick
what was the longest key so far I think
I saw on the board that someone was
estimated to have it for approximately
12 I'm sorry for teasing
so that's good to be nested its retina
it's very hard to diagnose them so
whether they're attractive the next
problem looks from all of these
outbreaks exact scene associated disease
that is caused by virus on
like sir one more question with the goal
of an eradication how much of an issue
do you think underreporting is and I'm
thinking in particular about areas where
like you mentioned earlier there's an
ongoing conflict perhaps areas where
medical care is denied to for example
female children and then that in
combination with the fact that many
western or more and more Western
personnel as in those countries whether
it be NGOs or Western Armed Forces is it
possible to stop immunizing as long as
underreporting is going on and is that
an issue this and detect fires
type 2 eradicated in my day or them so
there isn't people so I think both the
major Asian that's why even if you stop
say there's been no polio cases for five
years
this is going to go on will it be
possible to ever stop immunizing here it
is weather situation allows it to happen
really beyond wh 0 0 Therese
thank you very much please join me in
thanking professor Hawking